welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who's tighter than perceptus
receptor
in this video we're breaking down
transformers war for cybertron trilogy
earthrise
the title feels longer than the series
itself but that doesn't mean that there
isn't a lot to unpack from it
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down our thoughts on its story
ending and what we can expect in part 3
which we now know is titled kingdom
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the series yet then i highly
recommend that you check out now
make sure you smash the thumbs up button
if you enjoyed the video and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into transformers
earthrise
okay so the first chapter siege saw the
war between the autobots and decepticons
as both sides tried to get the old spock
at the end of the season optimus prime
threw it into the space bridge which
hurtled it across the universe
in a moment that was very well if i
can't play with my ball then no one can
now using the ark that was supposed to
take him and the rest of the order bots
away from cybertron
he journeyed into the bridge with a
small sect of soldiers whilst
other ones remained on the planet and
they become some key characters in the
entry
the space bridge itself actually
exploded and though it seemed like the
main characters might be dead
all the optimists out there they held
out hope
thankfully the post-credits scene
revealed that they were indeed still
alive
though exactly where they were was
completely
unknown now i know some of you just want
to learn about the ending of this season
rather than having a full recap so i've
left a time stamp of where that begins
in the video just in case you want to
jump ahead
now if you're still here yes sod those
lots and as we predicted last time
the quintessence sort of play a big role
in the entry
and we watch is a group of mercenaries
hired by them end up rescuing the order
bots
this is a big i told you so for everyone
who said i was in the wrong last time
but i i'm going to be dropping a lot of
theories at the end of this so
i'll probably be getting them wrong and
that'll be complete karma for me
now in case you don't know the
quintessence are actually an ancient
race that are known as galaxy white
traders and businessmen
they possess advanced technology and
travel the universe looking for life
forms to deal with
so it does make sense why they come
across the ark this sets up one of the
key storylines with the autobots which
sees them trying to locate the all spark
and retrieve it
so that they can help their allies back
home that plot point also kinda ties
into the next focus which
centers on elite one who remain on
cybertron at the end of siege
she pretty much steps into the shoes of
optimus prime this entry
and helps to lead the resistance now the
old phrase is decepticons keep on
decepticoning
and we discover that megatron has been
putting both his allies and the order
bots in prison camps
realizing that cybertron is a dying
world he's decided that the best way to
survive is to vacate the planet
and you very much get the strategist
side of him in this season
rather than seeing him simply as a
ruthless dictator
early on we discover that he's been
harvesting the spark from both autobots
and decepticons
in order to power a ship known as the
nemesis
he even altered the fighting arena into
a giant laboratory
and this idea of something once filled
with action and entertainment
being made into something more cerebral
actually reflects the storyline itself
the dark lord heads up his own empire
tries to get one of the protagonists to
join his side
and though he could be seen as evil he
cares only for his racist survival
which makes him a really compelling
villain now the star wars comparisons
don't stop there either
and because we know this is a trilogy
you kind of go into it with the mind
state that it's gonna leave a lot of
things up in the air
and it certainly feels like a middle
chapter throughout i hate the phrase
it's the empire strikes back of blah
blah blah
so i'll use a better one it's the attack
of the clones of
the series and by that i mean it's far
more grounded than the first entry
and instead of all our action it focuses
on character development
and the key players going on their own
arcs in their own groups
hey hey that's empire strikes back now i
don't want to force
the star wars comparisons anymore but if
elito wan and ko are the han solos of
the story
then optimus prime is very much the luke
skywalker
captured by double dealers mercenaries
they're taken before odysseus
who operates in the shadows as one of
the villains in the entry
i love how they referred to it as the
breaker of shackles i don't know if
that's a reference to daenerys in game
of thrones becoming the big bad
but it was appreciated like dany it
freed a lot of life forms such as the
autobots and decepticons
so that they would not have to live
lowly lives however they rose up against
the quintessence
and dcs very much wants to get revenge
for what it sees as an act of betrayal
now what i always loved about the design
of this character is the fact that it
was pretty much a living council that
had to deliberate over decisions
this allowed for multiple personalities
to come forth
and made for some excellent dialogue
scenes however
we don't really catch the character in
its prime
and pretty early on the dominant one
takes control
i like dcs this had me split and i wish
they'd not had the other characters head
off
as i'd been looking forward to their
appearance for a while especially
especially the puns i'd been saving
now i get how this idea of one person
making all the decisions instead of
democratically
is reflected in megatron but i'm not
sure if doing this was completely the
right decision
the main one is still pretty fun to
watch though so i can't really complain
too much
now after turning down megatron's offer
elite one and co
escape as does optimus from dcs they
travel to a stalled space bridge in the
nebulon system
which has a station keeping it open this
mary celeste
star cruiser seems completely abandoned
but we learned that it's actually
inhabited
by a scorpenoc this fan favorite
actually hails from generation 1
and it was binary bonded to lord zara
who was the leader of a faction of
nebulans
scorbenock is actually a triple changer
that can alternate between a giant
scorpion which is how we're first
introduced to it
a giant and a defense base we only
really see the scorpion and default form
but
you know we've got some time to talk so
i thought i'd just add that in to be as
informative as possible
after tracking the arc through what
seems like the help of double dealer
the decepticons arrive just as optimus
is about to blow the station
and here megatron have a big battle as
always it's amazing seeing the two
opposing leaders face off against each
other
and this fight actually made me realize
that they want the same thing
they just go about it differently both
have regrets
and they actually have quite a good
exchange in the aftermath of their fight
which cements that both are pillars of
their societies
opposite ends of the spectrum that
create a necessary balance
through scorpenoc we discover that the
quintessons ruled over him
and his people and that they controlled
them with an iron fist
scorpinox sees the decepticons in
autobot war as being nothing but a game
to them
and this sets up the latter part of this
series it ends with the autobots and
decepticons arriving on earth before
they're ambushed by odysseus
and they then crash land on the planet
here we watch as dinobot discovers the
ark
and this obviously hints towards a lot
of things going forward
now in order to fully discuss this we
have to talk about one of the big
flashbacks
of the series there is a point where we
catch alpha trine and skylinks fighting
for the matrix
and the former banishes the latter to a
dead universe
this is similar to the original run in
which he was cast out
and like that the character has gone on
an inner journey in which he's conquered
his own demons
his opposition to try on is of course
miradan optimus and megatron
and through him we discover that the
matrix is within optimus
believing that the bearer of the matrix
is the key to saving cybertron
he helps the group and megatron also
discovers galvatron
who very much acts as a guide for the
antagonist
now megatron and galvatron are very much
one and the same
with the latter being what i consider
the future version of the character in
many respects
there's very much a reflection of the
good guys and villains having their own
people that want to guide the next
generation down a certain path
and this introspective look at what's
come before and what could come
arguably feels like the most human part
of the season
i actually believe that we see the end
of their arcs played out here
i think that in kingdom when optimus
gains the matrix back
that we will see how corrupting it is
once more skylink stated that he will
have a choice
i think that the matrix will push him
even further down a darker path
but that he will fight against this and
eventually succumb to what it does
skylink says he must either allow the
matrix to find its next path and
sacrifice himself
or usher in a much darker future now in
my opinion
doing the first choice will allow for an
alternate version of himself to step
forth
much in the same way that we were
introduced to galvatron
i think that optimus could emerge in a
new form and this
could be why megatron calls him orion
now orion
was before optimus and the chronology is
a bit off on that when compared to the
original run
but i think this idea of dual identities
is hinting towards things coming down
the line
i'm not gonna put my amazon prime on it
being orion
instead of optimus but obviously yeah
let me know if you think he will take on
a different version
now we know that megatron needs to
become galvatron at some point
i think that the matrix may actually be
the key to this
we've already seen how it changed
optimus and made him given to his darker
side
so when coupled with megatron's more
charming personality
who knows what's gonna happen again i
know that's sort of different to what's
come before
but those are sort of where i see things
going
now galvatron clearly comes from a
timeline in which he's a slave to
unicron
who i believe will become the big bad of
kingdom
in case you don't know this planet-sized
machine is actually a supervillain
that's appeared in many transformer
timelines
and he should be seen as a sort of god
unicron can devour realities
and it brings chaos wherever it goes
thus i think the new forms of optimus
and galvatron
may have to combine in order to take it
down
now in the original timeline megatron
clearly lost
but this journeying of his past shows
that he wants to prepare his younger
self
for what is to come he instills this
idea of hatred further into megatron
and thus he may destroy unicron before
he even comes to power
galvatron also passes forward the golden
disk which is a very important object in
transformer law this carries a message
on it not only about earth
but it's also the key to unlocking
transwarp technology
now the season ends with us seeing
dynabot and in the beast wars animated
show
he was actually part of a group of
predatons that stole the golden disc
this was their mission and i kind of
have a feeling that in the first
timeline they succeeded
the disc was then likely given to
megatron which is why he was able to
take it and then pass it on to his past
self
now this is a lot of timey why me wibbly
wobbly stuff
but by my count that means that there
are two discs in the past
there's the first one which was in the
original timeline
and then the one from the alternate
timeline which was given to megatron
we know from the feature version that he
does eventually get it but him handing
it over to his past self means that
he never needs to send dinobot to get it
which yeah
creates an alternate timeline look i'm
as lost as you are however this does
leave room for dynabot to question what
side he's on
i think that's similar to the beast wars
animated series that he will switch
sides because of this alteration
now the synopsis that we have for
kingdom state worlds collide when the
maximals and predacons join the fight
coming together with the autobots and
decepticons in an epic battle
that will alter their destiny forever
this is not only hints at the predacons
and maximals being a part of it
but the word alter also signifies to me
that a lot of things are going to change
we already have leaked toys for the next
season which show the characters in
their beast wars form
including optimus primal and more so
this idea of altered states is further
coming through
but whether we have time to do another
switch or not i really don't know i
actually think that the show will go
beyond the trilogy
and after the war for cybertron one ends
we will get a new one that carries on
from it
though this is obviously still
unannounced i think this is where
galvatron will be dropped and so on
as the next season will probably be too
tight to introduce it along with all the
beast wars stuff
i know some of these theories probably
sound a bit off but clearly things are
changing and
stepping back and looking at everything
that's what makes the most sense to me
now as for the show itself i did really
enjoy it and i think so far they've done
a great job
of rebotting the franchise i love the
way they're pulling beast wars into it
too
and this feels like a complete and
concise collection of the chronology
the other characters on cybertron kinda
got put on the back foot
i still feel like this entry did a lot
in terms of character development
i'm really hyped to see what happens
next the last series dropped in august
so
hopefully it won't be too long before we
get the next one
and if it's here before this summer i
think that'll be amazing
anyway this was great and i'm scoring it
an 8 out of 10.
now the winners of last month's
competition are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers
i'll send you over a copy of the 4k lord
of the rings set
the giveaway was so successful that for
january we're being extra generous
and giving away three copies of the
hobbit and lord of the rings 4k box set
to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the season
the win is going to be announced on the
30th of january so make sure you keep an
eye out
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
his stock materials which will be linked
at the end
we go over the entire second season so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more
without the way thank you for sending
through the video i've been paul
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care peace